[Musique]
bonjour à la réunion bonjour le monde va
très bien mme aller mieux
comment il est alors je vous avais
prévenu cette saison 2 on va voir aussi
des artisans et aujourd'hui c'est le cas
on est donc chez jp et lulu dans leur
savonnerie artisanale alors des savons à
la menthe
mais savons que le cumin les savons
géraniums bref une symphonie d'odeurs
pour contenter notre petit nez jolis
messieurs dames
oui oui toujours du bond on n'est pas
sorti de l'auberge
venez
[Musique]
elle fait des bulles de savon
des mots qui lave à l'intérieur
d'un geste d'un souffle c'est selon
le ménage en apesanteur quand le moral a
chuté à 0 d'une parole à parachute placé
pour bonjour comment ils les voient bien
tranquille ou merci d'accueillir nos
déjà berlin peser renée est alors dites
moi où est ce qu'on est
c'est un magnifique endroit alors là
dans la savonnerie de piton saint-leu
savonnerie artisanale jeux couverts on
fabrique tous ses bons petits savants
bon pour la peau écologique économique
je suis pas déjà rien comme entrant dans
l'atelier j'ai l'impression d'être au
paradis des parfums c'est hallucinant
que ça sent bon c'est chouette
eh ben tu sais moi je vais découvrir un
petit peu là tu vas me montrer tout ça
si tu peux aller 1 et plus vite
alors voilà là c'est le savon qui en
séchage en fait on va jouer un petit peu
avec un petit peu avec l'aromathérapie
par rapport aux vertus des huiles
essentielles et compact en tonifiant
franchement j'ai l'impression d'avoir
des plateaux voilà je sais pas je vois
la joie du nougat aussi là tu vois je
puis du pitaya ces jolis seins c'est
vraiment joli
mais bon ça ça sent bon et mais tu as
quand tu t es le gazon ta vie tu fais ça
et c'est bon tout de suite ça mais
j'aimerais ça
des savons
qui vient
des prix
bonheur en ballon
le monde y autant c'est maintenant mais
qu'est ce qui se passe enfin vous allez
faire une opération à savon ou vers le
sait ça donc on s'équipe autant pour
faire du cerveau pourquoi pas se
protéger d'eux d'accord d'accord mais tu
sais quoi
pour le coup je vais te laisser le faire
le truc on est d'accord c'est l'essai on
viendra tout à l'heure un vaut mieux
aller à tout à l'heure
[Musique]
et
par contre les enfants
la soude n'allait pas faire ça chez vous
un ça fait boum boum sinon donc monsieur
jp
il est professionnel il sait ce qu'il
fait c'est un artisan il a son atelier
avec tous les outils qu'il faut mais
sinon si on fait ça à la case ça va être
villainville un vilain jeu mais dis moi
qu'est ce que tu fais là
là on va peser le gras on va puiser le
gras les huiles végétales d'accord
parfait pourquoi l'une oliver est un
petit peu d'huile de palme parfait mais
l'explication j'ai rien d'autre à dire
l'unrpa
après que le fils en hiver culture
qu'est ce qu'on va faire
alors on va faire un petit peu de savon
dernier aspect que tu va m'aider je vais
t'aider je vais devenir un savonnier ça
on dit comme ça c'est ça d'accord est en
fait je suppose qu'il faut que je mette
pas là c'est sa faute équipe et donc
blues dans après le docteur house à le
docteur alex
bien sûr j'ai même mon habit yeux et
tout attention chirurgien du savon
monsieur messieurs dames
[Musique]
dis moi on va fabriquer quel type de
savourer avec quel parfum s'était alors
déjà on va faire du savon donc naturel
donc à base d'huiles essentielles donc
là on va prendre l'huile essentielle de
géranium rosa de l'île de la réunion
voilà et avec un peu de d'argile verte
d'accord est ce que tu peux m'expliquer
étape par étape
tout à l'heure tu sais j'ai vu il y
avait des mélanges d'huiles il fallait
peser
c'était assez précis tu peux tu peux me
dire un petit truc là dessus stop bien
sûr fait la fabrication juste avant
c'est comme la cuisine donc on va faire
des pesées d'huile et de so2 donc c'est
une réaction dite de saponification à
froid à froid parce qu'on va pas
chauffer les huiles donc cette technique
ça permet de préserver toutes les
propriétés en fait des huiles
essentielles des huiles végétales
tout d'abord il faudra verser tout
doucement la soude dans l'huile et
j'amène inverse
d'accord on va sauver tout doucement
suis très doucement tout la totalité et
vous devenez en même temps absolument
donc de tourner enfin presque
voilà voilà voilà comme ça bon je prends
mon petit truc et je tourne doucement
comme ça aussi
la montée comme une mayonnaise c'est
vraiment la cuisine ça c'était si en
fait c'est ça qu'on tourne au fur et à
mesure on s'en va là ok et dis moi tu
peux mettre toutes sortes de chez pas
des fruits et je parle des goyaviers
grande bible comme ça je pense aux goyas
viella on peut voir dans sa valorisation
on peut faire de la purée de fruits non
par exemple on fait de la purée de
carotte pour la couleur pour les
vitamines
enfin voila on peut franchement on peut
on peut laisser libre cours à notre
imagination
on peut utiliser les produits de la
ruche du miel propolis pollen etc
on peut même mettre du lait dans du
savon peut mettre des argiles des
plantes séchées enfin c'est vraiment
ouvert
j'ai l'impression que le ciel déjà plus
ou du clown
[Musique]
on va tourner jusqu'à ce qu'on voit une
trace à la surface je vais te montrer
d'un un stop et c'est au moment de la
trace qu'on va mettre les additifs
naturels en fait donc là les additifs
ici ce sera à huile essentielle de
géranium et les insulaires
[Musique]
même temps
ah bon drôle de bruit donc la
candidature aux états unis j'ai retrace
en fait c'est parfait la moye des
maladies c'est parfait d'accord voilà
c'est comme ça
[Musique]
très bon point pour l'argent
j'avais beaucoup de boutons je me suis
mis des masques j'en ai plus
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors par contre tu vois si je bosse
avec lui ben voila quoi les pertes les
pertes voilà tu vois je suis un très
mauvais en fait je suis mauvais en fait
je suis très mauvais c'est triste dit
moi il faut attendre de l'étape on a
fabriqué le savon aase à ce bloc de
savon il ya combien de temps alors après
avoir fait la patte de savin donc on va
moule et on va attendre 48 heures avant
de démouler
voilà donc là tu vois bien c'est bien
dure voilà et puis on va laisser un mois
de séchage donc c'est le temps
nécessaire en fait pour que la réaction
se termine voilà quarante huit heures
pour démouler et un mois de séchage
voilà quelle différence ya entre entre
ce savon artisanal qui est vraiment bon
vous avez tous vu cessé d huile de coude
tu vois en tournant en 1 est justement
le savon industrielles 6
je peux me permettre nous sommes jetés
les i tout à l'heure on travaille à
froid on va pas chauffer des huiles déjà
ça permet de préserver toutes les
propriétés des huiles végétales et des
huiles essentielles et en plus ils vont
rajouter des conservateurs enfin bref
des produits on n'a pas besoin au petit
méchants riches les produits chimiques
implique ce qui pollue l'environnement
la tuque ou dab dab dab
[Musique]
et ben moi je dis bravo
tout simplement
sa faune si ça semble alors voilà on est
sous la véranda tranquille après après
un dur travail ou où j'ai appris à ces
jeunes
comment faire le savons dis moi comment
l'idée de faire du savon est venu en
fait on voit comment l'industrie
comment la peine de tous enfin comment
commander comme on fait pas attention à
tout le côté écologique et même nous
invitons à ses maîtres de nos produits
sur nous même c'est pas terrible et en
fait je pour prendre une démarche
vraiment bien naturel on peut le faire
moi c'est parti de là puis l'amour des
plantes
et puis j'aime apprendre j'aime sncm
boulot c'est sans fin en fait tu peux
apprendre tout en tout temps et continue
à te perfectionner jeu pourra nous
retrouver bas sur les marchés forains
mais ça vous ne seront pas emballé on va
vendre au poids donc à la découpe donc
les gens ici tu veux
venir acheter un kilo de s'aventurer
repartir avec un kilo savants ou 50 g
100 g
c'est au poids écoutez moi je pense que
je vais partir déjà avec beaucoup de
tristesse
j'attache beaucoup domaine en cours lit
salut voila je montais vite sinon je
tout prendre tu étais un très bon la
fontaine
merci de m'avoir appris tout ça moi j'ai
appris beaucoup de choses
je vais redescendre un petit peu dans
les bas et moi en tout cas je vais
passer vous voir c'est oublié
[Musique]
elle fait des bulles de savon
démont qui lave à l'intérieur
d'un geste d'un souffle c'est selon
le ménage en apesanteur quand le moral a
chuté à 0 d'une parole parachute placé
pour alors voilà l'émission se termine
on a des petits on s'est arrêté en bas
du piton saint leu sur une petite aire
de pique nique
on ne peut taper le petit paris le
dimanche samedi en famille tranquille ou
voilà moi je précise quand même que les
artisans sont là pour vous ils ont la
qualité le savoir faire le métier
consommé artisanale consommer réunion
produits consommés parce qu'à un moment
donné
l'artisan s'est bien d'accord ok pas ok
bon ben moi ce que je vais faire c'est
que je vais vous dire au revoir
un monticule et gros mais j'ai fumé quoi
ça va revenir
mais alors on n'est pas sorti de
l'auberge
moi je vous le dit mais moi je vous le
dire on n'est pas sorti de l'auberge
d'accord bon salut la compagnie
[Musique]